hallo mein name ist sogar herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu seinem neuen
video mit dem titel eingeblendet ich
mache es seinen gästen nach weil in dem
video was ich vorgestern hochgeladen
habe von dem aktuellen troika lima haben
mir das ein paar hater vorgeworfen
deswegen wollte ich da ganz kurz darüber
reden aber vorab erst mal kurz ein paar
organisatorische dinge und zwar erstens
gestern kamen können hier weil ich den
ganzen tag unterwegs war und deswegen
einfach keine zeit dafür gefunden habe
dann fragen mich außerdem sehr sehr
viele leute auf 1 2 millionen abos patch
will kommt und leute ich glaube ich
stehe gerade bei irgendwie noch 5000
abonnenten bis zu den zwei millionen
also sollte das irgendwie in zwei drei
tagen oder so wenn es so weiter geht der
fall sein ich hab im september über
100.000 neue abonnenten dazu bekommen
und ich bin euch da auf jeden fall
dankbar und versteht das jetzt nicht
falsch aber damit hätte ich halt
überhaupt nicht gerechnet und deswegen
werde ich wahrscheinlich kein krasses
special machen aber ich habe so eine
kleine idee als wartet einfach ab ich
denke in zwei wochen kommt dann
irgendwas also eigentlich bin ich ja
kein mensch der sagt okay war 2
millionen das ist für mich eine zahl die
auch eine million oder tausenden ganz
normale zahlen so das ist jetzt nicht so
dass vom schritt von 1.000.000 999 1999
das team zum übermensch dazu kommen
damit man die zwei millionen mega feiern
muss aber es wird eine kleinigkeit
kommen als special dann sehe ich auch
unter meinen aktuellsten videos immer
noch kommentare die entweder buch oder
kissen heißen
bezogen auf das gewinnspiel den man ja
entweder ein kissen gewinnen kann oder
ein buch weil beim einen kanal abonniert
und buch beziehungsweise kissen die
kommentare schreiben und leute das
funktioniert nur unter dem video hat
sich euch hier mal ein paar linke und
zwar wenn ihr wirklich an einem
gewinnspiel teilnehmen wollt und halt
entweder diese schwarze kissen oder
dieses buch von mir gewinnen wollen
zusammen mit zehn signierten sticker
müssen erst unter dem video machen
welche gar eingeblendet habe also es
bringt nichts wenn ihr unter jedes mal
der video schreibt kissen buch damit ihr
eure chancen steigen dadurch nicht ich
komme sofort zu der samen des ursache
aber es geht noch größer glaube ich um
zwei dinge die ich euch noch sagen muss
gerade sind die videos in berlin
beziehungsweise in potsdam und ich habe
sehr viele leute bei twitter
angeschrieben habe ich denn da hingehen
werde
video kommt ja gerade und morgen ist
glaube ich auch noch einen tag bei dem
video der ist bei morgen feiertag ich
war heute schon nicht dort und werde
auch morgen nicht da sein weil ich die
video der ist einfach nicht so feiere
ich fand es in köln diesmal baulich so
cool und ich denke ich werde auch aber
hast mich die ganze zeit hier nächstes
jahr in köln werde ich auf jeden fall
wieder dabei sein weil ich einfach in
der nähe liebe und aber berlin ist für
mich halt ich müsste da hinfahren und
ich mag die veranstaltung einfach nicht
so dass das ist so ist das leute kommen
und dann werden die alle aussortierten
dann kommen neue leute das ist halt
total und shell ich finde ich deswegen
habe ich mich halt dazu entschlossen
dieses jahr nicht auf die video dehst in
potsdam zu gehen ich hoffe ihr versteht
das und noch eine sache die sich auf den
minister bezieht und zwar geht es um
diese kissen dort hinten um genau zu
sein diese schwarzen ja hinten
eingeblendet sind wir ja denke ich
mittlerweile alle wisst ja eigentlich in
jedem video mittlerweile weder am 10
oktober kommen diese schwarzen kisten in
lucka shop und viele hatten sich gefragt
ob dann die weißen kissen nicht mehr in
dem shop sind also quasi die weißen
durch die schwarzen ersetzt werden nein
es gibt dann beide im shop also die
schwarzen kommen quasi nur noch zu den
weißen dazu und bei den männern schwarze
skizzen bestellt am 10.10 kriegt ihr
einen signierten sticker also ich glaube
ich habe insgesamt 1000 vorbereitet
allerletzte organisatorische sache die
man eigentlich könnte ich nur
organisatorische sachen sagen ist es
mein kanal ist dann hoch bleiben was sie
möchte warum grint sich hat eigentlich
wie vorhin schon gesagt ich bin nicht
bei dem video days in berlin aber ich
bin nächste woche vom 6 bis zum 8 also
von donnerstag bis samstag in berlin und
da hatte ich mir gedacht ich bin
nachhaltigen sondern party von meinem
netzwerk studio 71 und da ich daran hat
insgesamt drei tage in berlin habe ich
mir gedacht ich glaube das ganze so ein
bisschen ich werde jetzt aber nicht wie
andere youtuber eine drohne mitnehmen
und zehn kameras und so sondern wirklich
nur eine cyber shot heißen diese kleinen
kameras cybershot oder damit so ein
bisschen sonne unterhaltsamen blog
machen also jetzt gar nicht darauf
bedacht dass ich so krass ist ethisch
effekte und
offen zeige sondern halt mir dass ich
halt versucht so ein bisschen zu
unterhalten und einfach so zu zeigen wie
es im sommer darauf vorzubereiten bald
kommt ein blog auf meinem kanal und
jetzt zum titel erstmal an alle leute
die jetzt schreibe ich jedem titel und
der konnte dem thema allerletzte ihr
dürft gehen wenn ihr sogar über so was
made ich könnte das video auch nennen
ich stehe vor der kamera oder ein bett
weil das bett im hintergrund steht ich
nenne das video einfach so weil es die
meisten leute interessiert da dieses
thema allerdings die meisten leute
interessiert ich allerdings mit den
organisatorischen sachen die wirklich
darum gehen warum kein video kiz
versuche die meisten leute von euch zu
erreichen denn ich die natürlich als
erstes versteht ihr dass ich versuche
das ganze relativ schnell zu sagen und
zwar unter dem video vorgestern wovon
ich euch hier nochmal was kleines
einwände baguette da haben sehr viele
leute darunter kommentiert das ist doch
von seven days you geklaut sei weil er
irgendwie ein paar tage vorher so etwas
ähnliches gemacht hat ich habe unter
meinem video auch schon im märz eiligen
kommentar zu dieser ganzen debatte
darunter geparkt der das ganze
eigentlich schon klargestellt hat aber
sehr viele leute haben das wieder nicht
verstanden und das soll jetzt überhaupt
nicht böse sein gegenüber dich der dass
hier gerade sieht oder irgendeiner
anderen person die das wir gerade sieht
sondern wirklich einfach nur bezogen auf
die leute mein fokus ist voll am arsch
was das für eine kamera hier
es gibt derzeit diesen trend auf youtube
dass einige kanäle sich irgendwelche
interviews mit beispielsweise cristian
ronaldo oder lionel messi herunterladen
weil die halt nicht gerade englisch oder
deutsch sprechen sondern halb
portugiesisch oder agent ihnen
versprechen ihren dahinten ich spreche
auf jeden fall sprachen sich 99 prozent
der zuschauer selber nicht übersetzen
können durchs hören und diese
youtube-kanäle schneiden das dann so
zusammen dass es so aussieht als wenn
diese ausländischen stars bisschen weise
fußballer auch ein deutsches video
reagieren und dann spielen sie
beispielsweise zehn sekunden von dem
deutschen video ab und danach zeigen sie
wieder
fussball beispielsweise cristiano
ronaldo und er sagt an irgendwas sowie
dvi d kamera und dann schreibe seite
unter bitte hin halten anstatt dem
original das sind im design will ich
finde ich habe ein gutes spiel für real
madrid gemacht schreiben sie dann runter
weil dieser youtube es echt beschissen
und es finde ich an sich sehr witzig
sogar und damit hat nicht seinen des
yuan gefangen sondern so kanäle wie
christie oder die anderen weiß ich noch
gar nicht genau wie heißen aber die
haben das sohn schon vor wochen
hochgeladen und 26 grad einfach nur auf
so ein video reagiert und myvideo war
nicht mehr so aufgebaut dass ich auf ein
bereits vorhandenes video reagiert habe
da jetzt auf jeden fall nachgemacht
gewesen bis er sie zumindest inspiriert
und damit würde ich auch komplett leben
können wenn ich dafür leute kritisieren
allerdings war es bei mir so dass sich
quasi das video auf dass ich reagiert
habe auch noch selbst gemacht habe
vorher das heißt wieder existierte nicht
einmal vorher das waren aber arbeitens
prozess bei mir von diensten samen sechs
stunden dieses video auf die beine zu
stellen so kate hat jetzt auch noch
nicht mal zwei tagen 600.000 aufruf also
es hat sich auf jeden fall gelohnt das
video zu machen das hat sehr viele leute
erreicht aber es hat halt 40.000 6 um
10.000 disler das jetzt mal an die hater
gerichtet die sagen dass ich mich zu
einem trend youtube entwickelt hätte ich
weiß nicht was falsch daran ist also ich
meine mode unternehmen gehen ja auch mit
dem trend was zum beispiel jetzt solche
farben angeht die ein bisschen
ausgebleichte sind also hättet ihr die
auch weil die einfach mit dem trend
gehen und ich selber würde mich nicht
mal als trend youtuber ansehen ich mach
doch trends eigentlich so ein bisschen
kaputt mit meinem content also ich
meinen alle badenden ähnlichen
lebensmitteln jeglichen substanz
substanzen nicht gerade einfach im
wasser und das ganze so ein bisschen
hoch zu nehmen seine die reagiert auf
dem bereits vorhandenes video von
cristiano ronaldo der angeblich auf
seinen konzentriert und ich mache es
einfach so dass ich mit justin bieber
maske aufsetzen das ganze total
bescheuert mache und sage baguette
baguette und allem was hin schreibe und
bei den musik lied rennen bin ich
einfach auch keine person die da einfach
vor der kamera sitzung solche reaktionen
zeigen wie oh mein gott
das gerade getan hat was suche ich mir
die sachen vorher raus bereitet das
ganze auf und so weiter und so fort also
ich versuche wirklich mich von trends
nicht komplett die trainings mitmachen
sondern diese auch ein bisschen
kreativer und auf meine eigene art
darzustellen und ich muss wirklich
zugeben ich habe mich von seiner gäste
inspirieren lassen weil man einfach der
zeit merkt dass jeder youtube kanal vom
wachstum extrem runtergeht und seinem
einen scheiß autofokus takt mich nur
noch was findest du die rein
hier ist meine fresse wir geben den man
ganz kurz ein bisschen zeit kommen 2000
jahre später dank youtube irgendwas im
algorithmus verändert und ihr merkt er
selber hat wahrscheinlich einfach mal
irgendwelche polnischen videos oder
sogar startseite das ist eben total
bescheuert deswegen gehen voll viele
kanäle derzeit voll runter von den seven
days in der zeit einfach richtig
durchgestartet und da habe ich mehr
respekt weil er eine echt coole ideen
also das ganze mit seiner mimik einfach
wirklich cool darstellt und deswegen
orientiere ich mich dann natürlich auch
ein bisschen an den themen aber ich
würde jetzt nicht sagen dass sie es nach
mache sondern dass sich einfach auf mich
wirken lassen und dann versuchen mit
meiner eigenen artigen die darzustellen
weil ihr findet ihr auch keine parallele
hinsichtlich kanal design video design
oder irgendwie schnitt bearbeitung et
cetera ich glaube ich habe das ganze
thema ist doch länger behandelt als ich
eigentlich machen wollte ich will in der
oldtimer 35 minuten es tut mir sehr leid
aber mir war es einfach wichtig das
ganze zu klären weil das video von
vorgestern zehntausende slice ich weil
ich das nochmal hier oben dann könnt ihr
nochmal sehen aber deswegen bestand da
einfach ein bisschen redebedarf was ich
jetzt noch gar nicht gesagt habe ist
dass dieser trend halt nicht von summit
ist hier erfunden wurde da von den
youtube die das jetzt seit ein paar
wochen in deutschland machen sondern es
gab vor mehreren jahren weisen interview
ich blende euch das jetzt hier mal ein
ausschnitt ein
da redet dieser typ besonders talkshow
auf irgendwas sprach ich habe keine
ahnung was das für eine sprache ist aber
damit fing das halt an dass immer mehr
youtuber dieses video genommen haben und
an andere sachen darunter geschrieben
haben vielleicht kennt ihr den trailer
autofokus ihr fox fox
hallo hier bin ich daher kam der trend
wenn ihr das wollt und dann ist das
ganze auch schon sieben jahre alt und
dann haben alle von diesem video kopiert
das heißt hated bitte alle aber nicht
ich nur weil ich ein bisschen anders
mache dieses thema weil ich dein video
wert aber irgendwie hat es mich
beschäftigt das was sie vor dem gebäude
damen und herren ich hoffe es hat euch
trotzdem gefallen auch wenn es jetzt ein
bisschen mehr sondern fakten
organisation habla video war es tut mir
leid dass mein auto fokus komplett am
arsch ist ich glaube das liegt einfach
so ein bisschen an der belichtung ist es
wie gesagt schon sieben uhr draußen weil
ich halt doch wieder den ganzen tag ein
termin war deswegen tut mir leid ich
lass euch jetzt auch in ruhe hier findet
ihr zwei die eingeblendet da könnt ihr
einen kanal abonniere damit was willst
du für ein auto formuliert findet ihr
noch mal das video eingeblendet was so
mega umstritten war mit justin bieber
reagieren
ich hoffe ihr baby nummer vier hallo oma
jetzt wieder doch nicht danke autofokus
auf jeden fall der bild trotzdem neuen
schönen sonntag ist glaube ich heute
oder